but yeah it's like saying i'm gonna play
with witchcraft and god will protect me
as like saying all right god i'm about
to jump off the cliff you better save me
to prove your and that's exactly what
jesus didn't do
jump off this cliff because the angels
will save you right and jesus said
thou shalt not tempt the lord thy god
so you mean to tell me that the bible
can have stories about superheroes but
hollywood shouldn't find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live it's the show where
we use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today and i want to start off by asking
you guys how you been
how you feeling today
feeling great yeah a little warm ready
to jump into this topic
topic you probably don't even know what
about
we're clueless
well
i was just scrolling through some
comments and
i found some interesting questions and
some line of reasonings that i want to
just toss at you right and
i think it'll be an interesting
discussion and hopefully help some of
our viewers and answer some of the
questions that i think
i mean they were asking us
and shout out to those who have been
like dialoguing with people in the
comments section that has been really
interesting to to view and we try our
best to answer people but there's a lot
of comments which we are grateful for
and i'm just i love the community that
we're building you know i'd like to
shout out our patrons thank you so much
for your support they've been an
integral part in growing this ministry
we just appreciate you if you'd like to
join our family and get access to
exclusive content you can check out
patreon.com the light studios or go
directly to our website
tv slash donate
if you want a more tangible exchange
check out our t-shirts i'm wearing real
eyes realize real lies
and
this design and many more can be found
at what's the website
lightwear.shop lightwear.shop
all right so
first question you guys ready
wipe this right off your forehead it's
okay like this is a safe space we can
jump right in
and also i hope you know
you're ready with your bible knowledge
as well because we're going to need a
lot of that to back this up
does the bible or
let me put it this way can deprive
depravity be found in the
bible depravity
you say yes
expound upon that depravity
bad things
violence uh witchcraft um i don't know
you want me to be specific no no that's
fine that's fine yeah that's good
give me some examples then does anything
come to mind depravity in the bible
uh david and bathsheba
david and bathsheba what's wrong with
them
well it was an adulterous relationship
it was a
murder in order to get a woman that
wasn't his
okay
it's a good one
any others i'd like one from each of you
how about that samson
samson what's up with samson oh man
samson
there's a lot of controversy about
samson he was he was quite the quite the
guy but
it came around at the end so he i mean
he slept with prostitutes he uh wanted
to
have a
woman that wasn't it was against his
parents will
and you know we were told to honor our
father and mother
it was it was a lot of a lot of things
he was he was uh
not a good character growing up okay
i've actually lately heard people say
that he's an anti-hero
trying to justify people like deadpool
and things like that
samson was an anti-hero
manasseh
okay he was a king of israel in fact i
if i remember right he had the longest
reign it was 55 years
and
pretty much you name it that was evil
and israel was
warned not to do it
he did it
and
he had a pretty terrible
terrible reign as far as an israelite
king goes towards the end of his life
much like samson
he
turned that around
but i think one of the the testimonies
about his life it's kind of twofold it's
it's bittersweet
yes he turned around and yes he he tried
to teach and warn the people in israel
not to do those things
but
the ball was already rolling
and
the short time that he have left
wasn't enough time to
necessarily turn that tide of evil and
so yeah it's good that
he turned but
you know there were consequences
for his actions
that's right
why are you brittany
i'm thinking of israelites and how they
had to go through
um like hundreds of years in slavery and
just not having rest
and things like that it was enough for
it was bad enough that god had to rescue
them from it
was that like awkward for you guys
trying to come up with
bad things in the bible i mean supposed
to be a good book right right
the bible doesn't shy away from these
tough topics no yeah okay so let's
switch gears a little bit can depravity
or if a better word can be used bad
things
can those be found in hollywood films
definitely yeah
all the way i don't know it's harder to
find one that doesn't have bad things
yeah well give me some examples some
recent examples we've made some videos
but
oh doctor strange
the sorcerer supreme
okay yeah i think that's interesting
because a lot of the themes in hollywood
are in the bible like i mean like you
were saying with david and beth sheba i
mean that is a very
that's scandalous right that's
scandalous for
right it really is and it's like you
know he is taking somebody else's wife
then he gets her pregnant then he's like
i'll just kill this guy you know and so
that is very scandalous and it would
make a great hollywood film you know and
it has it made tons of money right so
that leads me into the question was
there a movie like because
huh there was a movie about david and
bathsheba
well yeah there are movies about david
and bathsheba but just the relationship
right um just
i think hollywood lacks on giving you
the moral and the end like
the son was his firstborn son by her was
killed you know it was
god it was a judgment from god and he
did repent
right
you're jumping into the answer which is
good um and i want more uh along those
lines because the question is how could
we tell people to stop watching
hollywood and indulge in the bible when
they seem to have a lot of the symbol of
similar things
themes well why aren't they going to the
bible if they like those themes in
hollywood why is it so hard for them to
read like why not do this it's an
exciting book guys there's a lot of
stuff in here absolutely yeah it also
just um
i know we hear we hear the phrase that
like
either life imitates our art imitates
life but i mean the bible is
and hollywood films as well are really
just showing human nature
in a way they're kind of doing the same
thing but yeah i agree with you that the
it's the moral at the end like at the
end of every story you just see wow like
god did this despite this person but at
the end of the movie you're like
i mean i know when i've watched romance
films like i've been like
you completely lose sight of
oh this person totally just left the
person they were married to right and is
with their old high school sweetheart
right and that is completely wrong but
it's like before marriage exactly and i
think tonight
it passes through my mind because by the
end i'm like well they totally deserve
each other because that was they were
like meant to be but it's like he
completely left someone completely
heartbroken so
oh go ahead no no that's fine i'll talk
right after you
okay all right so i have two points to
make so what i remember watching this
one clip of this guy and he was he was a
producer and he said he said he was
telling someone at another lunch i think
it was actually a movie he said look the
point of hollywood movies is to
titillate the mind you gotta titillate
the mind he's pushing this really
pushing this thing you want to titillate
the mind you want to reverse the story
on them so make them go wow i can't
believe i i i didn't see it that way and
so what the whole point i've heard this
said over and over again by hollywood is
take something that's
a belief that the majority of people
hold
use the story to reverse it around so
that when you reverse it around and they
see it they'll be like oh i didn't see
it that way i gotta go see that again
and i gotta tell some about this because
this made me think a whole different way
but oftentimes those those morals or
values that people hold so close
are the ones that are
in the bible right and because that's
general christianity right and so what
you have is is people flipping around
whether or not you should stay with your
significant other whether or not you
should murder or hate someone or whether
or not you should steal there was a one
movie i watched called jumper right and
so this guy was going through portals in
time i love sci-fi and so and so i've
had to quit it but it but it made me
think about it and i was like wait a
second he just jumped into that safe and
jumped out and took all that money
i didn't even think about that being
wrong because you know the guy needs
money he needs to get away from the bad
guy
and he can't just go to the regular a
team apparently but
but
other thing i want to say the other
other point i wanted to make was that
oftentimes it has to do with
the uh the narration when you're in a
movie
the narration of the movie is set you in
the mindset of the character that's
often doing these bad things
and then shows you why they have to do
these bad things to justify to justify
it and then you you almost become
sympathetic and want them to do that
but when the bible talks often you hear
the bible narration say and so and so
sinned in the eyes of the lord and so
and so did wrong in the eyes of the lord
and you see the justified reasons why
that happens that you often don't see in
movies
and so there's a whole different mindset
that happens in the bible with these bad
movies versus
the uh the mindset you're put in by a
director that is
oftentimes against the bible as an
atheist and that hates the bible
putting yourself putting them putting
people in that mindset to understand
something totally different for me
that's the problem with the whole
situation that's the issue that's uh
that's causing the whole whole problem
between whether or not it's good to to
hold your
hold your uh to look at bible stories
and the problems in the bible stories
versus going to movies and saying i'm
okay to watch this because it's bad
things in the bible too right
yeah
yeah i mean it's really along the same
lines i don't know that it's really
different everybody's kind of saying the
same thing from a different perspective
um much of the bible's historical
commentary yeah you know it's not a
it's not telling you one way or another
a lot of times in a given situation
this was
right or wrong it's it's saying this
happened you know and then you know
after the story you might have
you know jesus later one of the prophets
or something like that or you know
somebody comes in and says okay now that
we know this story now i'm going to tell
you why this was was good or bad but a
lot of things are historical commentary
and that doesn't mean
that it's
um
morally acceptable
so
think about that what do you think about
like a movie like uh hacksaw ridge you
know it's it's definitely got a good
moral it's about a guy who wants to keep
the commandments doesn't want to kill
anybody but it's a very graphic war
movie
rated r i mean there's yeah i'm sure
there's cussing and things um just
because they're in the military or
whatever but it's based on historical
facts
what do you think about it there's some
controversy about this
there is there is some conversation
about that
um
you go burst
oh you want me to go first i have a
whole different take on it so oh no i'm
curious like what's that we haven't
talked about this so we don't know what
your whole different take is on my
personal channel i talk a little bit
about this i don't i don't personally
like i think it's a great moral story i
think there's a lot of very good points
in this story um i don't think it's
necessary to put all those things before
my eyes that i don't i don't like i
personally don't like gore at all and i
hate it i mean we're eventually
i mean it's part of society
it's in history and all this other stuff
but
do you have to go and if i don't have to
go see it i'm not gonna go see it uh
that's that's personally me because if
um
if i'm constantly setting that stuff
before me it's gonna change my mindset
so so let me tell you a personal story
my wife grew up uh in in a christian
household but um someone she knows often
brought her to horror movies and she
would always go to these horror movies
and always come back and so when i said
we got married and i was like hey i want
to move out to the country i want to get
she told me this she said no i'm not
moving out the country that's where
horror movies are made
i said i said whoa whoa wait where did
you get that idea from i don't
understand where you why do you think
that's where horror movies are made and
so she started naming off all the
different horror movies that are made in
the country until this day we go down a
road and we're we're like she's like
nope nope turn around
i know where this leads and this is this
is where this is where we end right here
children of the corn
you know all these all these
chainsaw massacre right and so and so i
had to i had to statistically bring it
out and convince her and say look
there's less
less that goes on in the country than
there are in the city and and it was a
lot to make this shorter a long story
short we eventually did move out and uh
she loved it being able to walk down the
driveway and and open your door and not
have to see the neighbor next door
anyway but it was it was
it was quite a revelation to me to hear
her say you know i i've had these movies
change my mind with all the score and
stuff so to to the point
i think
hacksaw ridge has a fantastic
storyline and has very good morals and
very good information
but i'm just not sure i want to
go down there and see all that terrible
stuff so i'm gonna i'm gonna agree with
you before i say the rest cause i'm
gonna say this just to stir the pot a
little bit okay
some of the most
gory horrific scenes in the bible are
when jesus is at the end of his life
you know so i can see somebody coming at
it from from from that perspective but
there's a whole point to that
right just like and there may be a point
to hacksaw ridge my own personal opinion
is the people that were making that and
i know the people that were making that
um i know that i have met the director
and you know a lot of those people that
were on the board of trustees for
um
hacksaw original that i know why they
were making it
and they weren't
making it
for
people who
were familiar with the story
if you know what i mean
you know they're they're trying to reach
an audience that's very different from
themselves an audience that would be
very difficult having said that i'm not
saying they did the right thing
i'm just saying that's why they did it
their church is having fortnight day or
whatever you're trying to reach the
world yeah not not not necessarily
justifiable tactic but that is why
it was done that way because they're
saying you know what there's these
people in the world they don't know this
story
we'd like to introduce them to the story
and the character
so that we can introduce them to other
information and so they put it out there
you know and supposedly there were all
these controls you know they had a
member of the board of trustees on set
at all times and things like that but
um
hollywood does like to take
liberties
um
anyway
but
i still agree with you i don't think
it's for the average
you know it's not i never went and seen
it you know i don't care to put all that
and i think it's appropriate to
sometimes read about and understand even
even watch and understand what happened
to some of these things but
but to put it before your eyes every
single time even if this is a genre that
you enjoy
i think there's something wrong with
that
oh
cool i i have a question because you
said that um one of the most i guess
gory parts of the bible is when jesus
was dying
and
i think i disagree with that because i
remember like you don't think it's corey
no it is gory but i don't think the
bible
really tells how like gory it was
because i remember when i was reading it
um it's just he was beaten they put a
crown of thorns on him he was flogged
and i never really understood what that
meant until i watched like passion of
the christ or something like i had never
given i've never seen a crucifixion i my
mind could not grasp what that meant
it was just said and like
it was like vague kind of to me
so um
so what do you think is that a good
thing or a bad thing because i think
sometimes we read things in the bible
and you don't put yourself there it's
just like and jesus was crucified and
here he and it's like oh yeah we we were
so desensitized to seeing him on the
cross you know on somebody's wall and
it's just like oh that's a nice piece of
art no there's somebody dying right like
it's crazy to think that we just
we've almost become desensitized to what
happened to him you know cause like one
someone
sent us a comment when um
there was a social media post about
everything that christ had went through
for us and there were some verses and
they said okay well people from the
holocaust went through words that
there's people who have been through
whereas and i think that could be a
result of the bible being vague and what
jesus actually went through that's all
part of the experience in my opinion
because in that line
you can go deeper in your own study
what was the roman empire like during
that time what did it actually mean to
be flogged maybe i can go and find some
historical evidence to back up the story
of the bible if it was all laid out
there's some internal evidence though as
well says his visage was marred more
than any other man so in other words
it's like
he's essentially unrecognizable by the
time they get done with him that's how
horrific
of an experience that he went through
and i know i've heard these things about
people from you know the holocaust went
through worse as far as like bodily
torture and all that but it wasn't just
that that jesus was going through it was
much more than that so yeah spiritual
emotional you know psychological all of
that was
was put upon him right and i think with
the holocaust we see the images we see
like testimonies and all of that so i
think like you said it is important to
go and see what the roman empire was
like what were their tactics and to do
that in-depth study
um about those things
so from the perspective of a questioner
mikey you brought out you know
the the reason for the stories in the
bible is to bring out morality right um
morality is always part of the
was part of the thought in including
that story in the bible
is that to say that hollywood doesn't
have morale or doesn't display morality
on screen
i wouldn't say all the time i mean
people might try to say it you know
they're like oh it's a underdog story i
i don't really see a repentance type
story usually it's usually like
that's an important word what what is
repentance repentance means turning from
wickedness you know and and a lot of
these stories like
deadpool or something like
foul mouth fornication all the killing
people but they're doing it for good you
know batman he's a vigilante he's taken
into his own hands and he's
killing people for good and he's not
repenting at the end they're just saying
no look he's doing good it's yeah
they're thinking it's justified
yeah but doesn't the bible do that like
we see like god does call people into
battle or to
kill people or hold
like they'll just so i'm thinking of for
example um
david and goliath i mean that's one you
know god but then god called batman to
punch a dude to death in the street
right but i mean if you're looking at
the two and they're doing bad things for
good because i know that that's also
controversial it's like god tells us not
to kill but then there are people that
he sent to kill you know so it's like
how do you
what's the difference between that and
in the bible in hollywood because you
can both you can justify both the same
way that they're both doing it for good
yeah but
what i was getting at is
batman isn't
like a christian he doesn't have
christian values at all you know
a lot of these people it's a sympathy
for the devil type story like
the joker oh he's just misunderstood
that's why he's nuts and kills people or
whatever it's we're seeing it a lot you
know especially with venom he's
possessed but he's trying to do the
right thing or you know i don't even
know if he's trying to do the right
thing but he's
he's killing bad guys
but what i'm saying is there's no
repentance at all there's no like
moral at all it's just like yeah i could
be possessed and kill people and say i'm
doing it for the right reasons
so with these stories that you're
talking about
there there is a there is a difference
and
one of the one of the primary
differences
is when you read the old testament you
find that israel is
is operating under
a lot of times a theocracy
which is you know they're given their
directions directly by god you know
either through the prophet or the or the
king sometimes it's a monarchy but you
know there's still some communication
from the prophet like god has asked them
to do certain things
we don't live
in that time period anymore we're not
living under a theocracy and there's no
part of
batman's storyline that i'm aware of or
any other superhero where it's like i'm
getting my directions from god to carry
out in other words i'm doing it of my
own accord it's my judgment my justice
and that puts me as the highest moral
authority
it doesn't it it's not putting god as
the moral authority and furthermore
there's a lot of
instances
where again some of this is them making
their own decisions
and some of it is yes god asked them to
do something but if you look there's
plenty of times where
when they've put themselves in god's
hands and said god we need you to
be our deliverer
they didn't have to march i mean they
might have marched out to battle but
they didn't do anything
god you know took care of the situation
for them whether he sent in
hornets or or something else you know to
drive the people or they wound up being
afraid and turned on them their selves
or what have you so
it's not that god is this evil monster
and he's just out to
you know send a nation in to slaughter
people that's that's not right that's
not the point and it's i don't even know
that it's a majority of the time i think
it's a way for people to pick that out
and say well that's in the bible
therefore i'm justified in my thinking
about this thing over here
i want to bounce off that i think that's
it this is a very interesting topic
because people often say you know what
you know god told people to kill people
what what is up with that
i i i believe that
well we can see in the bible where when
they were at mount sinai they were they
were there and god said hey you know
what put put a fence you know an area
around where the people don't go left my
brightness break out upon kill these
people and so when god came he was it
was it was a traumatic event i mean god
is god he's coming down on the mountain
and it's burning the tops of the
mountain you can actually go there still
i have friends out there and the top the
rock on the mountain is still burnt up
there and so and so when he came down
there was thunder there was trumpets
there was lightning it was it was
traumatic and when he spoke the people
like look
moses
all that you will all that he says we
will do just don't let him talk to us
because that was scary and so and so god
said look i gave you a covenant
but i haven't even told you the
stipulations behind it yet you've
already signed it by saying all that you
say we will do okay if that's if that's
how you want to do it then that's how
you do it and so he gave us he he had a
plan for a covenant
the the original covenant of god the
everlasting covenant and then we
modified it saying we will take care of
all this stuff we will do it by works
that's what happened and as soon as that
happened we they found out they couldn't
do it because they started worshiping
the slam this this ox or the cow in
there
yeah and so and had all that and so they
broke the covenant that they wanted
at that time and god's like look all
right
we will make a new covenant based on
better promises promises not by you
that you say that you will take care of
this stuff but promise is based on
my promises that i will write this on
your hearts and so during that whole
time he was like if you want to keep
this yourself
you will fight these wars
but the way i wanted to keep this for
you is i wanted to send hornets i wanted
to send hail i want to send and destroy
these people the way i can take care of
it for you that way you don't have to
kill you don't have to do this stuff
and i believe that towards the end of
time as
we get closer to the end of time and as
people
just before god comes we're going to
have that people that revelation speaks
about the saints in the bible that
follow the lamb wherever he goes and
what did the land do when he was
completely innocent he didn't fight back
he didn't he didn't draw his his weapons
and start swinging right i think it's
the same thing going to happen at any
time with with god's people he's not
going to draw us we're not going to draw
our weapons we don't see anything in
scripture that says
and when they came after us we took out
our guns and we slew them yeah right
we
sadly
take it as it is and if that happens
god delivers us yeah that's really
interesting powerful point i don't i
didn't think about it that way that god
had a plan and there's multiple
instances where god has a plan and he's
like all right you guys want
birds are gonna birds gonna come out
your ears you want the meat or whatever
you know
you want a earthly king all right you
get earth the king like
he
he kind of changes his plan for
according to the people and then it
doesn't usually go the best way because
his plan was better but
even deeper plot twists with like
batman or whatever he's based off of
hades he's the dark knight i mean he's
literally like satan who's
glorified as the good guy saving the
city so they're literally making movies
saying yeah satan's a hero
okay
well i want to pose this question and
also remind you to uh keep in mind the
perspective someone may be coming from
when asking this question
do you think it's confusing that god
commands us to not have anything to do
with witchcraft and a reference to that
could be deuteronomy 18 verses 9 to 11.
um
but then there are so many people in the
bible who he makes participate in
witchcraft some examples about moses
when he put his hand in his cloak and it
came out disease and he put it back in
it came back and it was healed
or
philip teleporting
right
these stories are pretty wild i suggest
you check them out
the bible cool book moses rod that's
right
or like jesus multiplying food so you
have uh these instances where these
people are participating in in
witchcraft right um
but god doesn't want us to participate
it participate in it today
that's kind of confusing so the bible
defines witchcraft as a sin
okay to
say that jesus participated in sin would
completely nullify
everything that he came to do yeah
so
there's a there's a different i
understand where people are coming from
i understand what they're getting at but
there's a difference between miracles
miracles exactly and
you know the miracles or witchcraft or
whatever you want to call it satan can
do yeah there's a difference so there's
a source you're saying yeah there's a
different source
miracles and witchcraft because the
action is there so you're saying that
christ didn't participate in sin but the
action is there so how can we reconcile
that
witchcraft is self-serving
and miracles are for serving
others
so when jesus came yeah he did all these
things but it was to bless other people
he wasn't doing that to make himself
more powerful he wasn't doing it to make
himself look better he wasn't doing
anything to serve himself in any way
now
that's what people call white witchcraft
exactly like white magic because you can
use that to like heal a bird that has a
broken wing or you know you can use it
for good as they say or even keeping in
the context of movies superheroes are
saving people's lives that's a good
thing that's a selfless act
the the other thing that's important is
that is where is the power being drawn
from
you know so jesus was completely reliant
upon the father there is nothing in
witchcraft that relies upon god
at all
never it's never a source so witchcraft
is always
you know either
chanting a spell summoning another being
awakening something inside yourself
it's always more um
it well i'll just say it's not it's not
drawing on god as the source of power
and strength yeah it's also i think very
deceptive because um i think the devil
can come to us in whatever form that we
will accept
and so if you do have like
um
i guess like with white magic no one's
going to actually think i'm not pulling
my source from satan you know it's it's
going to be something that is more
accepting more loving more
you know
just i i don't it's like we're
everywhere
yeah
like healing crystals
right or it's just coming from the earth
or the universe yeah
yeah i i agree with what keith said it's
all
where is it coming from if you're
reading spells out of a book and
chanting that's not at all asking god
you know
god literally told moses put your hand
in your cloak and he obeyed you know
god told abraham slew your son and he
was going to obey like
obedience is important and if moses
would have denied that then he would
have been
you know disobeying god
but what we're gonna say
i'm just thinking of like moses putting
his hand i feel like god was also trying
to prove a point because during that
time they did have witchcraft and all
these other things that they were doing
in the culture and so god is trying to
display like i can do the same things
that they do and even greater so obey
like i'm the real god not what you were
taught to follow that's perfect because
that leads right into the next question
so moses he stood in the face of
pharaoh's witchcraft and overcame
right now i say witchcraft we we don't
believe that it was witchcraft but just
to give some context in exodus chapter
seven um moses threw down his staff and
it turned into a serpent and then
pharaoh's two magicians well they threw
that on their staffs as well and those
became serpents but then moses's
serpent ate
their serpents and then turned back into
a staff it's crazy so
god is supposed to be more powerful
right
so then why can't we engage in any movie
or even tarot cards because in the face
of those things god is more powerful
in fact his
actions can look similar to the actions
of the op the opposing side and he comes
out
he overcomes that so are you asking why
isn't god why isn't it since god's more
powerful why doesn't he keep us from
those bad things no us as
his children why can't we engage in
those things because he's all powerful
so it shouldn't really matter like why
can't we disobey god and protect us from
that that's another way of putting it
are you saying why can't we prove to
others that god is more powerful that's
another way of putting it i mean he's
like just there's nothing this person
sounds like there's someone who wants to
engage in these things and they've seen
certain
bible stories of people engaging in
similar things as witchcraft and
everything turned out okay god was more
powerful and it was sorted so why can't
i engage i think it's because there's
rules of engagement going on in the
courts of heaven and um the way they uh
that we can interact god has given us
specific things that said you know what
you can you have a choice and this is
your choice if you choose this side
the engagement of spiritual realm has
access to you from the dark side the
dark side right
whereas
if you choose this way then you'll be
engaged
with us
and your choices
uh determine who which side you're on
and who helps you and i i think i think
that's that's the the big question the
big decision so i have a question
where does witchcraft turn out okay in
the bible
because that's that's where i was a
little bit confused with where you were
going like where does witchcraft turn
out like it's all hunky-dory right well
this is coming from the premise of them
thinking
the bible miracles are which exactly so
moses action of his staff turning into
spirit uh into a serpent was witchcraft
not a miracle or i mean the fact that
the bible has different terminology it
never says and and jesus performed a
magic trick you know
performed a miracle but when it talks
about what the world's doing it's
sorcery magic witchcraft
so it's important to have the right
foundation even going into the bible to
understand
these principles yeah i also think that
i mean as a christian why
like mikey mentioned don't tempt the
lord like why force
why put yourself in a position that god
didn't call you to be in just to prove a
point
um
i guess that could be self-serving in a
way if we if we want to say that um
witchcraft is self-serving because
you're not
god didn't call you to do that you know
he doesn't need you to um prove anything
for him but i think when looking at
moses he like god called him to do that
and it was for a specific purpose he
actually did want like god wanted
pharaoh for like his heart to be changed
you know he was trying to save a nation
and um they had like pharaoh had
believed in other gods and so there was
something that god was trying to do
there was a purpose for that it wasn't
like moses was like oh yeah my god is
better than yours you know kind of thing
so
like elijah did
elijah was cool but yeah it's like
saying i'm gonna play with witchcraft
and god will protect me is like saying
all right god i'm about to jump off the
cliff you better save me to prove your
and that's exactly what jesus didn't do
jump off this cliff because the angels
will save you right and jesus said
thou shalt not tempt the lord thy god
yeah
it's interesting i really wonder like
what's behind some of those questions
because
if somebody is like
thinking well i should be able to to do
all this stuff too it's
i'm wondering where is the motivation
and where's the trust because if god is
leading your life and god asks you to do
something god's going to enable you to
do whatever
but he certainly doesn't need your help
so
why do you have to go and seek some kind
of
way to empower yourself to do something
without god's
permission
or admonition
you know it makes makes me wonder like
if god needs me to
do whatever he's called me to do it he's
going to enable me and empower me to do
it and i don't have to worry about
you know am i powerful enough or do i
have the the skill set
you know he's he's got it it's because
the focus is on him the power is his i
am nothing
you know god is everything
and so
i guess i i don't see it like i need to
worry about that you know
if if i need to part the red sea
god's gonna make it happen you know
at the right time and for the right
reason
yeah if you don't do it he'll find
somebody else to do it yeah i mean i'd
like to read a verse for you guys
talking about freedom of choice it's
coming from
first corinthians chapter 6 verse 12 and
i want to read it from the the common
english bible because i like the
verbiage but um
it says i have the freedom to do
anything
but not everything is helpful
i have the freedom to do it to do
anything very poetic you know
but i won't be controlled by anything
so
in context the writer is talking about
sexual immorality but we can apply it to
life in the general context that
principle stands strong through every
scenario
but i want to pinpoint the difference
between what being in control looks like
versus what being in control doesn't
look like you know when when our
desire to indulge
overpowers our willpower
that's addiction you're not in control
right and there's there's another text
in 2nd corinthians chapter 10 verse 5.
going back to the king james casting
down imaginations and every high thing
that exalteth itself against the
knowledge of god so putting away those
things
and bringing into captivity every
thought to the obedience of christ
see entering into a relationship a
serious relationship with god it demands
sacrifice
right sometimes that sacrifice hurts not
watching certain things not indulging in
certain things
but when our will
aligns with the will of god when we
start having the kind of thoughts he has
and the actions that he has he gives us
the power to overcome
and to like control these desires
that's where our source of knowing right
and wrong and being able to overcome
these things should be coming from from
jesus and he's offering to help us
follow these guidelines because within
our own strength it is impossible it's
tough we can come up with a million
justifications as to why we can or
should or shouldn't do certain things um
but with the help of god with the
mentality of god with the mindset of god
with the good foundation and entering
into studying the bible without our own
biased conception um concepts in our
heads already
it just makes all the difference you
know the the the having the mindset of
this is what i can do and i take joy in
it because it's bringing glory to my
lord versus oh i can't do this i can't
do that it's such a misery
it's just an amazing it's a better it's
a more life it's a more enjoyable
outlook on life yeah and that's my
encouragement
to to those watching to those
questioning to those battling
we can give answers all day
but it's a heart issue it's it's a
conversation between you and god
and um coming just from the right place
and
we appreciate the questions we are open
to the questions we love uh
being in conversation with you that's
what we're here for right
and so we welcome them and and we we
pray that you continue to search
and that you open up your heart to the
lord because there is a verse that says
if you seek me you will find me if you
search for me with all of your heart
right uh any closing thoughts from you
guys i do i think that what you what you
said about love and heart issue is is
super important because
what i found is a lot of times people
say well you know what you're a legalist
because you're doing all this stuff for
the lord or or you are or you know
nobody can know if someone is a legalist
or not this is a pet peeve of mine so
i'm going to stand in a soapbox for a
second because
no one can know if someone's a legalist
or not because it's a heart issue and so
if you let's for example you say hey i
love my wife or i love my husband i want
to bring flowers to them right
you bring flowers to them because you
love them right
well someone standing at the counter
there who has had a bad relationship
they're looking at you and going hey
look at that guy at the cash register
he's he's trying to win his wife's life
what would you do wrong
manipulator such a works
in such a worked relationship he's a
legalist
right
he's such a legalist well how do you
know that you don't know that you don't
know if the guy is actually there
because he truly loves his wife or he's
trying to win her love by these acts
he's doing it's the same thing with god
are we doing these things because we
love him and because we want to serve
him or are we doing these things to win
our way into heaven
and nobody can see that in your head
nobody knows that and so no one can sit
there in the comments as a keyboard
warrior and say you legalists right but
people do that all the time and so i
think i think the mindset is we we need
to
we need to humble our hearts and we need
to think you know what there are people
there are that that want to truly love
god yeah
amen
we're very um
i think a lot of times we're very
hedonistic in our thinking
which means we're
we're kind of
trying to
always seek pleasure
um and avoid
pain and
the the tricky spot you can get into
that with christianity is that
we oftentimes think that we know
what's most pleasurable based on our
experiences
and so we are
we set ourselves out to be the masters
of our own happiness
which means
i don't have to trust god for my
happiness if i'm in control of my
happiness therefore anything that i do
that brings me pleasure well
how could that be bad
you know if i like doing this or doing
that or watching this kind of movie or
listening to this kind of music or
whatever if it brings me pleasure and it
brings me happiness how could that be
bad but
that also puts us in a position where
it begs the question do we really trust
god
do i trust god with my happiness because
if i do
then god says you know
you'll have pleasures at my right hand
forevermore
god is the author
you know of of our happiness he knows
what's best for us he knows what will
truly make us happy
and if we trust god we don't have to
worry about
you know if our lives are going to be
happy or not
you know yeah is there going to be pain
along the way probably
you know what you have that either way
whether you're in charge or whether
god's in charge right so who do you want
you know where do you want your source
of happiness coming from is it the one
who knows you best better than yourself
or do you want to be in charge
[Music]
everything that we've touched on on
these couches are actually
full videos we have a bunch of them
we've been going for i think over two
years now
and by god's grace we will continue
going for as long as you keep watching
so thank you for watching every single
week thank you for your questions thank
you for your love and your support and
we'll see you next week on led live
hi you might not know me because i work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name is michael and i'm the
director of little life studios 3d
department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology
where we're trying to blend reality with
the virtual world
it's more efficient and offer us the
opportunity to make higher quality
productions with better visuals
by using the unreal engine software it
gives us the possibility to create
realistic
virtual environments for sets in a short
amount of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have financial limits
that's why we're working toward getting
an led wall in the future
because it will allow us to use extended
reality
this simply means that we don't need
green screen anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from led wall
which matches the subject and the set in
real time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so
that's what we've been up to here at
little eye studios
we're so thankful for the ways that god
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
[Music]
hey danique here have you ever asked any
of these questions like
why does the old testament and new
testament god seem so different or what
does the bible have to say about sex why
do we have to wait for sex until we're
married or maybe who are 144 000 or why
does it seem like god doesn't answer my
prayer where clearly he says ask and it
shall be given to you etc yeah i've had
those questions too that's why you
should tune in every single wednesday to
our brand new podcast the little light
studios podcast in which we seek to
answer your most challenging bible
questions make sure you look us up and
hit subscribe on spotify apple podcasts
or anywhere else while you listen to
your podcasts we'll be there every
wednesday see you then
[Music]
you